هناك قصف للطيران في نسمع تحقيق الطيران
والمضادات الطائرات من قوات الدعم السريع
التي تحاول ابعادها من هذه المناطق عموما
اليوم شهد عمليه
حركه للطيران كانت كثيفه منذ وقت الصباح
وحتى هذه اللحظه والان نسمع اصوات الطيران
نحن الان في
سوق بحري في محطه الوسطى هذا سوق احترق
بالكامل خلال
قبل اسبوع
وهذه هي اثاره ما زالت مضادات الطيران
تضربه بمناطق مختلفه هذه قذيفه ربما
نسمعها الان
تنفجر في هذه المنطقه
نحاول ان نبتعد قليلا من
المناطق التي يبدو ان فيها جزء من
الاشتباكات او جزء من المواجهات طبيعه
القتال هنا هنا الطبيعه تعتمد على سلاح
الجو وعلى المدفعيه التي يحاول الجيش
اعاقه قوات الدعم في هذه المناطق التي
تنتشر الطيران في هذه المنطقه النشط جدا
ومنذ
الصباح في مناطق مختلفه سجلنا ان هناك تمت
عمليه قصف لمناطق اخرى تابعه لقوات الدعم
السريع قال الجيش انه استهدفا من خلال
الطيران
لكن هذه المنطقه ما تزال
طبيعه الاشتباكات فيها مبنيه على القذف
مبنيه على
المقذوفات والنيه على القصف ومبنيه على
المدافع ومضادات الطائرات
ليست هنا في هذه المنطقه بالتحديد هنا في
المحطه الوسطى في بحري اي شك من اشكال
المواجهات المباشره ما بين قوات الدعم
السريع وما بين الجيش الجيش يبدو انه يتخذ
استراتيجيه
محاوله الاضعاف اضافه الامداد بعمليات
قصفه لمناطق التابعه لقوات الدعم السريع
او اي عمليه من عمليات الامتداد او
تجمعاتهم